there there's a report that came out
yesterday from the athletic i think it
was mike sandow there's one general
manager and look we got to couch all of
this because who knows really it's all
driven by chatter at the combine right
but there's a gm that believes the
buccaneers are interested in teddy
bridgewater which would be the ultimate
misdirection
they have us thinking they're focused on
tom brady and philip rivers because
bruce arians mentioned them by name last
week that could be cover for taking a
straight line shot at teddy bridgewater
who was 5-0 last year as a starter and
his best game statistically came against
the buccaneers right so you know that
there's
there's reason to think that bruce
arians may have been thinking during
that game damn i want that guy not this
guy i want that guy and he may go get
that guy and uh from the standpoint of
reducing mistakes i kind of like the
teddy bridgewater idea chris well that's
exactly it that's where you start right
i mean teddy bridgewater i mean he is
teddy bridgewater because he limits
mistakes he does not play that style of
football now that can be frustrating too
because you know he can be a little bit
of a charlie check down at times where
you want to go man come on push the ball
down the field uh but maybe that's what
bruce arians is looking for maybe he's
been there no biscuit right
i still can't reconcile no risk at no
biscuit with being upset that a guy had
30 interesting
no risk it no business i i i think your
point's real there too you know i think
that's a little bit of the mantra of the
offense at times i mean you made the
points there's reasons carson palmer and
peyton manning through a lot of
interceptions of the bruce arians
offense too you know so yes there there
has got to be some give and take there
from the bucks to know that jameis was
being pushed that way and that leads me
perfectly into why
i don't buy the teddy bridgewater to
tampa thing because i don't see
bridgewater as being a no risk it no
biscuit type of quarterback that's just
not i think ultimately he would start to
frustrate bruce arians as much as jameis
winston because he'd be going stand in
the pocket look there's going to be a 30
yard completion and you you threw the
check down and got the ball out of your
hands why'd you do that i think he would
get just as frustrated with that as he
would with james throwing you know 25
interceptions so yeah that's one where
like i i know it kind of makes sense but
i think i gotta see it to believe it
before i get get behind that
maybe he thinks he has a better chance
of coaching riskett biscuit out of
bridgewater than he does reeling in
james maybe maybe you're right maybe
he's just going you're right it's the
lesser of the two what guys
give me a guy out there that you would
put in that no risk it no biscuit
category that would be a perfect match
for what arians tries to do well i i
will say like tannen hill is a guy that
looks to strike and throw the ball down
the hill field right right away i mean
that was where my mind went with that
more than anything you know after that
hey philip rivers is that guy too he
certainly is i mean we've seen he's he's
risked a lot and lost a lot of biscuits
because of it you know and so that that
would those are the two i think more
than any that jump out to me about that
type of mentality at that position
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports